[Musique]
c'est précisément pour ça que je veux
président mesdames et messieurs voici
votre prochaine vice-présidente infiniti
jackson elle a déjà un taux
d'approbation de 80 et un compte des
fans sur instagram
apparemment il ya une cassette sur
laquelle on te voit proféré une insulte
envers les gays tu as une idée de ce à
quoi ce fait référence est ce que tu as
vu l'heure qu'il est vous fermez là je
suis pas d'humeur pour vous connecter ce
que tu dit dans la vidéo elle a dit
paupiettes elle a traité un journaliste
ouvertement gay de pau [ __ ] [ __ ] de
merde ça y est c'est terminé
vous savez je vais devenir président des
états unis gellos simplement un fait je
deviendrai président je vous préviens
décolle pas avec mon rêve ton ambition
m'a fait très peur à brands hatch a fait
ces lycées mérite mieux que toi si tu
veux le battre il faut que tu acceptes
tu as froideur intérieur et tulle assume
pleinement
on déteste payton bien plus que toi vous
croyez que je devrais lui quoi puisque
je crois je suis pas sûr d'être
quelqu'un de bien t'as pas besoin d'être
quelqu'un de bien tant que tu fais bien
autour de toi
parle-moi de ce qui ferait une
différence pour toi qu'est-ce qui
t'intéresse
je n'arrive pas y croire que je suis une
[ __ ] avec un coeur de pierre et de
la glace dans les veines
cette jeune fille voudrait votée elle ne
coupe pas voter sans sa carte
d'étudiante sinon des élèves d'autres
lycées viendrait pour voter en toute
illégalité
c'est ridicule il ya des chances que
payton sont homosexuels astrid est une
furie
ça sur un match je n'arrive pas à
comprendre en quoi le fait d'avoir
traité ce que cet homosexuel de pau
[ __ ] puisse provoquer un tel scandale
c'est fou ce à quoi c'est pas une
insulte non mais c'est vrai chacun ses
goûts ah bon d'achat faut le faire
assassiner
c'est trop tu prêt à tout pour gagner
vous appelle pour dénoncer un crime
c'est toi qui fais ça
c'est tellement dur de te voir twitter
essayé tu vas changer le monde payton
après tu sais
[Musique]
j